So we've talked about, this is kind of like everything
that makes up the kind of core fundamentals,
all of the way that things communicated,
the various tools available to us,
ways to optimize things,
how these things are actually done,
the functions that we can call about traveling.
The last thing is kind of a callback
to our very first session
when we talked about the kind of power
of Unreal, of the editor itself,
that one of the great things
about testing editor functionality
of testing multiplayer functionality, sorry,
is the editor gives us some kind of capability.
So you might ask the question
when you're doing a multiplayer game,
to test multiplayer, do I have to make a build every time?
The answer is kind of, is yes and no.
So we're gonna go into that a little bit.
So we talked about the kind of editor configuration
right in our first session.
I think it was like one of our first slides.
A little bit like standalone,
the editor configuration is,
when we build for the editor,
it's a configuration that is both server and client.
The reason that this is the case
is because the editor can spin up
as a server and a client.
And that gives us basically a pretty accurate,
a very, very true to finished game representation
of actually how this game might be executed
in various environments,
be that standalone, be that listen server,
be that dedicated server with clients connected situation.
We can also simulate bad ping
to see how our gameplay and network systems
kind of perform under various conditions.
If you have this presentation downloaded,
you'll see in the presenter notes,
there's a link provided
that will take you to the documentation
about how you would utilize
that kind of network connection emulation.
And we can also provide a couple of launch parameters
to the editor
to kind of specify various things
about how we want this connection to be.
It's worth mentioning though,
the kind of yes, but no part of this
is that whilst the editor will provide us
with a very good representation
of what our game will look like in editor,
you should be making regular builds of your game
to make sure that you can't,
you cannot and should not purely trust the editor
to give you 100% accurate representation
of how your game will occur
in a server-client relationship.
You should be making networked builds of your game,
testing that in a server-client setup
to make sure that all of this stuff is definitely true.
That should be part of your workflow.
You shouldn't be purely relying on the editor.
So a couple of the options available to us
we can control within the editor.
We can talk about the number of clients.
So obviously this defines the number of clients
that we want to create when the game is launched.
Network simulation, this is the kind of option
that we talked about below.
This is about whether or not we,
there's a kind of default configuration
for kind of good versus bad connection.
We can also specify our own if we want a simple,
but I think the document that I just mentioned before
and the kind of Unreal documentation,
it talks about exactly what this bad connection actually is.
I think it's like 10% packet loss
and 500 millisecond ping, I think.
And then we've got the various net modes,
which is, like I said, we can play as a client
where the editor will launch a dedicated server
in the background and will create a client for us
and we will connect to that server.
We can play standalone, which is kind of our single player
or local multiplayer,
if we have multiple clients version of the game.
And then finally listen server,
where if we have multiple clients,
it's our editor will be the server and,
will be the listen server,
so it's server and client
and every other client will be a client
connected to that server.
So I'll actually just kind of very briefly
demonstrate this.
Some of those settings are actually available
through your project settings.
So the things like the network connection stuff
isn't available through this kind of quick access,
but if you go to the level editor play section,
project settings,
oh, sorry, editor preferences, my apologies,
editor preferences and level editor play,
you see these, all these options here.
So this gives you the kind of more fine grain,
full bodied set options,
but the kind of quicker way to do this
is just in this drop down here
next to your play and editor button,
you've got a couple of settings just here.
Number of players you want connected,
what net mode you wanna be in,
but then you can also quickly jump to your,
to that same editor preferences section
just by clicking on the advanced settings here.
So if I were to play,
the kind of standard thing you would be in
is standalone and what this means,
ignore the kind of print strings in there for a second,
what this means is you're kind of playing this game
as though you were playing either single player
or in a kind of like split screen multiplayer mode.
So if I go to a number of players two,
what that's gonna assume I'm trying to do
is local multiplayer.
So typically that would be creating
like a split screen set up on your game,
depends if you've got split screen set up
and stuff like that,
but this is essentially the single player version
of your game.
Next, we've got kind of listen server.
So as I said, what this will do
is it will create the editor itself
becomes the client and server
and every following connection becomes a client.
So this is our server and client
and everything else for every other client
that you've chosen,
you get a little window like this.
So if I change this to number of players three,
not 34, that's probably gonna be a bit extreme,
but you'll see, I get two little windows,
one to represent each client
and you can actually see I have,
well, I have a kind of porn
representing each of these things.
I don't know why I currently
can't actually see the porns.
Maybe the porns are actually invisible.
Am I mistake on my part?
But, and then last of all,
we have play as client.
We don't have an option for dedicated server
because a client inherently implies
that a dedicated server
is gonna be created in the background
and therefore both the editor
and every window will be a client
connected to that dedicated server.
So in this case, this window is a client
and all the other two windows are all clients.
So that's the kind of end of the example
of how the editor works,
but I just wanted to quickly talk through the example
that I've set up in the scene
and the kind of example actor
that I just briefly showed off
and the kind of various things that I'm demonstrating
because this is kind of primarily here
just to kind of back up
and show you the ways that you can test the bounds
of some of these bits of functionality.
So the first thing that I wanted to do
is demonstrate to you what I was saying before
about the fact that you can't rely
on our with client code and with server code pragmas.
So what I've done is if you look at this,
my networked pawn that I've made,
this is just a kind of default pawn that I've created.
We talked about the default pawn
in our second training session.
It's just a kind of pawn
that has some floating movement functionality,
some basic collisions, some basic visuals.
And I've made a game mode.
It's possible that this game mode wasn't set up correctly.
So just let me quickly check that.
My networked pawn, no, that is the pawn class, okay.
So my game mode will essentially
create a spawn,
one of these networked pawns
for each of my clients on the server.
And then the client will end up
with a copy of every other client's pawn
and will be in control of their own local pawn.
So if I play this, again, you'll see.
Both are, well, easiest to do it in the editor
because you can see that this,
we've got three player states.
Like we said, this is the information
that represents the kind of global information
about the player.
We've got our, oh, this is
because I'm in dedicated server mode.
We've got one controller.
That's because I'm in dedicated server mode,
this is actually a client.
And so I've only got my own player controller.
You can see, I don't see the other player's
player controllers.
And if I move around,
okay, I don't know why I can't see the other pawns.
Maybe they don't have visuals,
but sorry, the frame rate going really terrible here.
Okay, I'm not sure exactly what's happening there
with why they're all kind of just rendering
in the middle of the screen,
but that's not even really what I was trying to show.
So the kind of main thing I was trying to kind of
display here, I'm just going to trim that back down
to two connected clients or yes,
or even just one actually for the purposes of
demonstration, it doesn't particularly matter.
First off, we've got this begin play functionality.
So if I kind of jump inside here,
you'll see what happens on begin play.
You'll see that I've written some if with server code
and if with client code, right?
So you would expect that on the server,
we print this string and on the client,
we print this string, right?
One thing that's worth bearing in mind is that when,
for the purposes of testing, when you do print strings,
actually what happens is that a print string
gets shown on both the server and all clients.
So you can't just rely on printing string alone.
You will probably need to say who is doing
the printing of the strings,
kind of know exactly where it's coming from.
So, but you'll see on begin play,
you'll see that both the client begin play
are called on the dedicated server and on my clients,
the client and the server according both situations,
even though one of these is the client
and one of these is server,
that doesn't seem to make sense.
But when you consider that this is in editor
and with in editor, both with server code
and with client code are true,
then this is why this is not a reliable way to,
you can't just put your server code in here.
You can't just put your client code in here
because that will turn your standalone game
and your editor into a big old liar.
So that's the first thing I wanted to mention.
Then I've got, if you download the project
that comes with this, you can obviously open this map.
It's just inside our content, 11504,
and it's just our example networked map.
And if you just go inside the level blueprint,
you can just see I've basically connected
basically a bunch of debug keys
just to demonstrate different little bits of information.
So I'm just gonna kind of drag that
onto my other window here.
So first off, we've got a,
what I'm doing here is I'm saying on begin play,
if I'm the server call, after five seconds,
call server do thing, client do thing,
and all clients do thing.
Now, if you look at what these functions are called,
these are on the networked porn,
server do thing is a server function.
So this is called,
this is typically intended to be called
from the client to the server.
This is a client function,
and this is called from the server to the client.
And then this is our net multicast.
And then this is called on every client connection.
So we'll see what that actually does.
We can also call this on when pressing the one key,
but obviously it's when we're in a server client scenario,
I can't press one whilst on the server.
So in this situation, I've had to do this delay.
If I am the server, do a delay of five seconds
and then call it just to kind of demonstrate that.
So I won't do anything for five seconds.
And you can see the dedicated server
is calling server do thing.
It's getting, it's all clients do thing called.
So that's the kind of network multicast
also getting called on our dedicated server.
You can see on the client,
only client do thing is called,
but the client is also receiving our net multicast.
So even though on the server,
all three of these were being called,
and this is on the porn,
only the server is receiving server do thing,
only the client was receiving client do thing,
and everyone was receiving the net multicast.
Okay, so that demonstrates that.
And you can also see what happens the other way around.
So bear in mind that this editor window is the client,
and I'll just wait a couple of seconds
for all those messages to disappear
so it's not getting completely over full.
So now that all the messages have disappeared,
if I just press one,
you can see when the client calls it,
the client server do thing gets called on the server,
client do thing gets called on the client,
and the net multicast is called locally on the client.
If I had two clients connected,
you would actually see that this kind of doesn't count.
This doesn't net multicast in the same way.
So if I actually just quickly do that,
if I change the number of players to two,
so you see when the server called it,
all clients do thing is called twice,
and that's because it's getting called on both clients.
Okay, and now when I call it from one of the clients,
you'd see we only get one all clients do things,
and that's because calling a net multicast from a client
will call it locally, but nowhere else.
It will also, when you call a client function
on the client, it does, that will come through,
but that's the intended behaviors that you are,
it is coming from the server.
Okay, so that's demonstrating
the different RPCs available to us
and what they do in different contexts.
Next up, this kind of thing that I was trying to prove
about the fact that it's only the server
that has game modes.
If I go to listen server,
and then I play with two clients connected.
So on the listen server, when I press two,
you can see I get a printout of my game mode name.
When I do it on the client, empty, nothing.
That's because clients don't get a game mode.
Obviously in the context that you're the listen server,
you are both server and client,
so you do have a game mode,
but I think you understand that discrepancy.
Next up, who has authority over an actor?
So as we said, net role is not the same as authority,
so it depends.
One of the easiest things to basically say
is who spawned this thing.
So if I press three, you can see we spawn an actor
in the middle of our level,
and then we're going to,
we basically call this check authority function,
and this is just a multicast function,
and all that does is try and find that actor
and then just print some information about it,
is who's printing this a server or the client,
and do I have authority?
So if I am the listen server, which I am,
if I press, sorry,
I think my game feels, it seems like it's frozen up.
Don't know why that is.
But if I press, sorry,
okay, so I don't know why that froze up,
but you can see when I press three,
I'm getting these actors spawning in
and just to kind of see what it's actually saying,
server has authority and the client is saying
it doesn't have authority, right?
And also the other thing that you can bear in mind
is that on the client,
I can see that those actors have been spawned in
because I did it from the server.
When I do this the other way around,
so I'm in listen server and client,
and the client chooses to spawn the actor,
you can see the, okay, too many bits of information,
but yeah, the client has authority
and that's because the client
is spawning these things locally.
And when I'm on the server, those things don't exist
because when the client spawn things,
they don't get replicated back to the server.
When clients spawn things, they are local
and therefore the client has authority over them,
but no one else is gonna know that it exists.
Okay, so that's that.
Then variable replication.
So this is, as you can see,
all I'm doing here is updating
a replicated variable on our actor.
And what you'll notice here
is that we get these two little dots.
This just says that this is,
when we're making changes to this,
we had this a little bit before
with when we had the fast path and the anim graph,
you watched the second session,
we talked about that basically denoted
some extra bit of information about the node.
This is basically saying you're making changes
to a replicated data.
So if I were to hit play now,
they kind of, we would see that kind of flow
that we've already talked about.
This is our kind of standard standalone mode.
That's the default.
And then we've got these various net modes available to us.
So standalone is our kind of like single player version
of the game, the offline version of our game.
You can, we've got this option for multiple players here.
This isn't, you might assume that this is actually
gonna be your kind of typical split screen setup,
but actually if you wanted to do
a kind of a test split screen,
simplest way to achieve that would be
if we go to our level blueprint.
And if I just quickly hook this in,
if you went to your begin play
and you created an additional local player,
that is how you would quickly test
what a split screen, oh, that's, yeah, there we go.
Okay, so we have both there
because I've done two number of players,
two and the create local player,
but you would see,
that's how you would achieve split screen.
But yeah, just standalone is generally
the same game in offline mode.
I'm just gonna unhook that create local player.
So then when talking about multiplayer testing,
you can use this to start from
your single player offline mode
and then kind of go through a lobby joining process
or something like that.
But if you're just trying to purely test
the multiplayer functionality,
that's where our listen server
and players client would come in.
So obviously there isn't an option
for playing as dedicated server
because the implication is that
one does not play on dedicated server.
So if you play as a listen server,
the editor is both server and the first client
and every additional client receives an additional window.
And if choosing players client,
then the server is created as a separate process
and the editor is just the first client
and every, including the editor,
every client is distinct from the server.
So let me just quickly demonstrate this.
When players listen server,
again, this isn't gonna be very obvious
what exactly is going on
because it is kind of all internal on one machine.
But as soon as we change this number of players up to two,
you'll see we get this little window appearing
and this represents our other client.
And you can actually see where it can have
in a multiplayer scenario that's already working.
So I can move around in my level
and you can see both of the clients moving around.
You'll just have to kind of believe me
that when I'm swapping between the window,
that is what's happening there.
Some printing of strings going on there in the top left,
that's just to kind of demonstrate some things.
So these are the various options we've got available to us,
the different nodes, the different nodes.
We can show the same thing with the client connection.
Again, in this situation, both of these are clients
and the server is just a third distinct process
that is neither the editor nor this little window
that's appearing here.
And then last of all, we've got obviously these,
you know, the advanced options where you can go to the,
change any of the kind of additional configuration settings
that you need, whether that's simulating a poor connection
or any of the kind of myriad of settings available here.
So that about kind of wraps up the kind of explaining
the engine part of this.
But what I was just gonna quickly demonstrate
is use this opportunity to just kind of reinforce
some of the things we've already talked about.
And that's what these print strings
in the top left are about.
This is a demo scene that should come with the project
if you download that.
If you just go to the content 11504 folder,
that's the one that comes with this,
that's linked to this session.
And so we've just got a couple of classes, a test map,
and then the other element to this is the C++ class,
which we've already looked at a little bit.
Just gonna close some of these windows.
So it's this my networked Pawn.
We've already looked at this a little bit,
but I'm kind of gonna go through
a couple of example scenarios
just to kind of re-highlight
some of the things we've already talked about.
So the first one,
if you remember all the way back to our first session,
we had this idea of the different command line,
the command line pragmas that are available
within each of the different configurations.
So we have with client code and with server code,
if you recall those.
And as we mentioned earlier in the presentation,
we can't, net mode is really the thing
we should be using to ascertain
whether we're on the server,
whether we're a client,
because whilst the temptation is to rely,
could be to rely on those, those pragmas,
it's not, they aren't reliable, essentially,
for reasons that we've kind of already discussed,
but just to kind of demonstrate it,
we've got the begin play here and with server code,
we've got this print string saying a server begin play
and with client code, we've got client begin play.
So if we are in a,
if I play as a listen server
and I've got two clients connected,
one thing that's worth bearing in mind as well
is when dealing with a multiplayer scenario,
when you're doing multiplayer testing,
the print strings will appear to every client.
So print strings from the server,
print strings from the client appear in on every monitor.
So it can be using print strings alone
and it can not always make it completely clear
where that print string is coming from.
So it's worth kind of adding
a bit of additional information.
So if I were to play again, we see these begin plays
and we can see that we've got the,
yeah, essentially we've got a client server begin play,
client begin play and server begin play
and client begin to play, sorry, from four times.
And that's because we have both the server
and the client printing both of these messages.
And that's essentially because we have two actors connected
and all of them are printing both of these things.
So that's kind of like eight messages.
So that's, you know, we can see immediately
that this with server code and with client code
isn't necessarily doing what we expect
and that's because we're in editor.
And as we said in editor
and when building for standalone configurations,
both with server code and with client code are true
because the editor can be server or client.
So you can't rely on that.
That's the first thing we want to talk about.
And then if, again, you can download this project
and kind of look at these things, but each of these,
then we've just got a series of kind of like debugging
things that are just bound to different keys
that are kind of there to demonstrate
different bits of functionality to us.
So the, also one thing that's kind of just very quickly
worth mentioning is we've, I've just made a blueprint
that inherits from our networked Pawn class.
The reason I've done this is just because this class
is using, is inheriting from a default Pawn,
the server version of the default Pawn
will replicate its location to the clients,
but clients that there's no kind of innate setup
for clients to communicate their inputs
through to the server.
So the server appropriately replicates the client's position.
So what you get is this set up
in a slightly strange scenario where the server Pawn
is moving around on everyone's representation,
but the client ones aren't,
they're just kind of stuck in their spawn position.
So all I've done,
this isn't necessarily the way you should do this,
but just to be able to really quickly demonstrate it,
all I've done is in the blueprint of the networked Pawn,
all I've done is on tick,
I've just checked whether that Pawn is locally controlled,
i.e. controlled by this connection.
And if we're not the server,
cause we don't want to be doing this on the server,
we only need to do this for client connections.
We basically just call,
we take our current location, our local location,
which we are controlling with our input
and calling this server,
this on server function to kind of set that Pawn's location
on the server.
And then it will get replicated out
to all the other clients.
So that's just a little bit of a hack.
This is not the way you would typically do this,
but I was just quickly trying to get this working.
So just, if you look at that,
don't take that as a lesson as onto how to do this,
because that is not really how you should be doing that.
It's purely for the purposes of demonstration.
So as I said,
the kind of key points that we're talking about here
is in this level blueprint.
So first off, we've got these kind of three functions,
right?
On our C++ class, we have server do thing,
which is our server function,
client do thing, which is our client function
and net multicast.
So the, if we've forgotten the server functions
are the ones that we are expected to be called
from a client,
usually by the owning client of an actor.
So that's gonna be the player
that is responsible for a particular actor,
normally either their player controller or their pawn.
And that's communicating to the server from the client.
Client functions like this are intended from the server
to an individual client,
normally the client that is owning the actor.
And then we have net multicast,
which is the kind of shotgun,
let everyone know about this thing.
So just to kind of demonstrate that,
what I've got here is a little bit of a setup.
Essentially, if we press debug one,
we call all three of those functions on the first pawn.
It doesn't particularly matter which one of them
because it's for any demonstration purposes.
And what we also do is we check on begin play.
If it's the server, then we also call this.
This is because obviously in a dedicated service setup,
there's no ability to press a button
because no one is actually inputting stuff to the server.
So if I go to a player's client,
so there'll be a distinct server setup
and I have two clients connected.
And then what you'll see here is,
so there's quite a lot of print string.
What I'll actually do is I'll change this
to be down to a number of players
because for the purposes of this demonstration,
we don't need multiple clients connected.
So after five seconds,
you can see the server called those functions.
And so server do thing is called,
all clients do things called.
These are both called on the server itself.
And then the client, client do thing is called
and all clients do thing is called.
So clearly when server calls server functions,
it does call them on itself.
When it calls a multicast,
it calls it on itself and all clients.
But then on the server,
the client form isn't called on the server.
It's only called on the client.
And then if we were to kind of like reverse this
the other way around, so if I press one,
this is, I am currently on the client
and we'll see what effect that has.
I might just wait for some of these messages to disappear.
Okay, so now when I press the one key,
we can see that client do thing is called on the client.
All clients do thing is called locally on the client
and also server do thing is called on the server.
So when you call a client function on a client,
it is called locally.
When you call a net multicast on a client,
And when you call the server from that client,
it is broadcasted to the server,
but the server doesn't receive the client call.
The server didn't receive the net multicast
when it was called from the client.
And if we extend this out to a two-player scenario,
the kind of other interesting thing here,
so we've got a kind of two, these are both clients.
And if we kind of, you know,
we'll have to unfortunately tolerate the fact
that we've got a huge amount of print strings
at the moment.
But when I press one on this server,
you see that on,
oh, that's a little bit confusing,
but essentially when we are calling the net multicast
from this client,
you can see that only it's only called once,
even though there are two clients.
And that's because net multicast called from a client
aren't broadcast to other clients.
This is there an RPC that is intended
to be called from the server.
So it's only when the server calls a net multicast
that everyone receives it.
Otherwise only the client that is doing the calling
will actually receive that function, receive that RPC.
So then if we just keep going,
next up, we've got this thing
that I kind of already mentioned,
which is about kind of proving to ourselves
that game mode only exists on the server,
very easy to test.
If we just go have number of players is two
and we should play as a listen server.
So the editor will be server and client
and the first window will be client only.
Then if I press two,
you see I get a print string of my game mode name,
that's the name of my game mode instance.
And if I go to the client and I do the same thing,
nothing.
And that's because the client has no game mode,
that class is null on clients.
So only the server has game mode.
Then we've got some code
that basically spawns an actor locally.
So after this actor is spawned,
we just spawn like a tutorial,
like that orange old tutorial character
from previous old Unreal tutorials.
And then we call this net multicast function
that basically on every element,
search it, they all search for all instances
of that class of actor
and basically print out whether or not
they are the server or the client
and whether or not they have authority over the object.
So again, if we're in a listen server setup,
so therefore when I do things from the editor window,
that is kind of a, it is a client,
but it's also the server.
So when I press three,
you can see the tutorial character gets spawned in
and you can also see that again,
probably too many print strings,
but you can see server has authority,
client doesn't have authority, right?
And also you can see that when I'm on the client,
you can see all of those enemies
that I've spawned in appearing.
But when I do this the other way around,
when I press three on the client,
you can see it says client has authority,
but the server doesn't even get notified.
And that's because again,
we're calling a net multicast from the client.
So that doesn't go through to the server.
And because these things are spawned on the client,
that doesn't get communicated over to the server.
So they won't exist.
And if we had multiple clients connected,
none of them would see these tutorial characters either.
So when you spawn actors on a client
that is purely local to that client,
not replicated and the client has authority over it.
Okay, so that's this kind of difference of authority,
depending on how that object get created.
Next up, we just have kind of
standard variable replication.
So all we're doing here is when we press four,
we update this variable, some replicated float here.
And we just change it from the kind of standard value,
which is zero.
You can see it's marked up as replicated
as we kind of, we explore this a little bit earlier.
It's marked up for and get lifetime replicated props.
So all of the kind of proper work is done.
You can see as well in blueprint,
when you edit replicated values,
you have these additional kind of like little icon
in the top right to show this is a replicated value.
So what, and the kind of other part of this
is just on tick in our level blueprint.
We're just finding all access of class,
all of the networked porn
and just printing whether where the server,
which entity it is,
and then what some replicated float value is.
So if I play, you can see those print strings coming in.
We have the serverPorn one and serverPorn zero
and clientPorn one and zero,
and they're all printing zero all the time.
And when I'm on the server, when I hit four,
you can see the client starts printing one
and the service starts printing one.
So that is, that value has been replicated
and it's present on the client.
You can also see obviously the ordering
is identical here, but it's, you know,
it doesn't particularly matter,
but it's just an interesting kind of thing
that they get access of class
and not finding them necessarily in the same order,
but the generally the replication is still working.
But again, if we were to do that the other way around,
if I were to play and I go to my client,
they're all printing zero.
And if I press four, you see the client changes to one,
nothing else does.
Because again, when we're replicating values,
clients don't replicate values to the server
and they don't replicate values to other clients.
It is the server's responsibility to change this data.
So if you try and change that,
even a replicated value locally on a client,
nothing is gonna happen.
They have to communicate that up to the server
and it's the server that then propagates that change.
So example five.
This is basically just a demonstration
of this onRep functionality.
So this is just another replicated variable.
It's just a vector and we're setting it
from its default value of 000 to 00100.
But the side difference here is we have,
if we actually look at that variable,
we can see some replicated vector is rather
than just replicated, it's replicated using,
and it calls this function allenVec.
Again, this is just a highlight that the name
of the function has absolutely no relation
to what it's actually doing.
onRep is important.
It does need to be called onRep underscore.
So if we go to onRep allenVec,
we just see what that's doing.
All it's saying is essentially when this value
has changed, print a string to say that value has changed.
So same again.
When I press, yep, just waiting for that
to print string to occur.
When I press four, oh, sorry, wrong one.
When I press five, you can see on the client,
it's received this replicated value
and it's printed it out as 100, which is what we expect.
And if I were to do that from the client,
I press five, nothing is happening.
And again, this is what we were talking about
when the rep notify is only getting called
when that value is replicated.
And if you are setting it locally, it is not replicated.
The same thing would apply for standalone.
We can actually just test that.
So wait for those other print strings to come in.
So we're not getting confused.
If I press five, I'm pressing five, nothing is happening.
And that's not because the value isn't changing, it is,
but our rep notify isn't firing
because it's not getting replicated.
When you set the value on a client,
it's not replicating to anywhere.
When you set the value in standalone mode,
So you cannot trust on rep to get called
in when that value is not replicated.
And the only place it gets called
is the place that it's getting replicated to.
It will not get called on the server.
And then example six is we have this same,
kind of a little bit more demonstration
of some replicated logic,
but there's a kind of additional caveat here.
So we have the second value, which is a struct.
And as we said, the struct application is absolutely fine,
but what I've done is, so this is a U struct,
which it needs to be, all of these things are marked up.
You can see we have some U property float,
some U property int,
but we also have some non U property float.
And what we have here is a function called updateMyStruct,
and we're passing in a prop val of 20
and a non U prop val of 50.
And if we go and look at what that function actually does,
updateMyStruct, prop val gets passed
into some U property float,
and non U prop val gets passed
into non U property float,
and then we're flushing net dormancy.
We don't actually need to do that,
but that was just kind of demonstrating
that function being used.
Technically, if this were now dormant,
that wouldn't be useful there, but it's not.
So if I were to play and hit six,
again, I'll wait for those print strings to occur,
five seconds, and if I hit six,
oh, sorry, I think I'm in standalone mode.
So I'll play as a listen client, listen server,
and I'll have two clients.
And now if I hit six, you can see,
it's printing out that the values were zero, zero,
well, zero, zero, zero,
and now they're coming in as 20, zero, zero.
So that 50 that we fed in isn't coming over,
and that's because that's going into a U property value,
a non U property value,
and non U properties don't get replicated, essentially,
even though this is a replicated struct,
which we're doing here,
even though we're setting the non U property value,
because the replication is kind of tied
into the reflection system,
if it's not a U property, it won't get replicated,
even if you change it.
The other kind of thing to mention here
is one of the kind of additional things
that you can do when you're doing
a replicated using callback,
is you can basically pass in,
you can add an additional parameter
that is the same type that is being replicated,
and that additional parameter will represent
what value that replicated value had
before it got updated.
So that is how we're leveraging this,
like printing the old value and printing the new value,
is that when you do a rep using,
and you make an on rep function,
if you pass in, if you add a parameter,
you don't need to do anything else,
if you just add a parameter
that is the type that you are replicating,
this parameter will contain the previous value
that had before is updated by the replication.
So that can be very, very useful for you
when you want to see what kind of changes are listed.
Okay, so that's kind of demonstrating
a couple of different things.
And then the last thing I wanted to show was,
again, just what I was talking about
quite a bit earlier in the presentation,
which is the fact that modifying individual values
of structs, they'll still replicate
and using this same on rep notify.
So you can see we're getting the replicated struct,
and we're just adjusting the new property int to 30 from zero.
I'll just wait for those print strings to appear.
And when I do six, you can see that same rep notify
is getting called, even though I only modified
a single value, I didn't modify the whole struct.
So that's again, proving that, you know,
you're setting a single member in a struct,
as long as that struct itself is replicated,
it will still all get replicated.
And that's about everything,
like obviously you can dig into this more,
doing things in the editor is a really good way
to kind of just be able to test the boundaries
of how all of these things work.
And that kind of really links back to the original point,
which is the kind of, you know,
the power available to us through testing
all this functionality through the editor
and what that provides for us.